now to be fair Comic Con is not all  about people think it's all about Marvel  and DC superheroes ladies and gentlemen  it is not one of the most popular comic  book styles in the world is Japanese  anime I don't we have any anime if you  if you are an anime fan this is for you  okay check it out great time what do you  think of my anime eyes Andi but they  also look creepy don't you think  [Laughter]  [Applause]  it you should probably just go on with  this yeah yeah yeah  you're sure you okay right why why would  you ask all right I don't know I love  that Andy that's Ivan I love both Andy's  but this is a great Angela  [Applause]  [Laughter]  what nothing nothing at all nothing at  all  wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]